we tend to think of change as something
that happens to us or these singular
events when in reality we are just
always in conversation with change and
because we think of it as these singular
events we often relate to change is
something that happens to us instead of
something that we're in conversation
with and so homeostasis is this notion
that living systems crave stability and
anytime that they are confronted with
change or disruption they try to get
back to that stability as swiftly as
possible so it describes a pattern of
order or stability and some sort of
disorder or change and then back to
order and allostasis is a process of
order disorder reorder so allostasis is
literally translated into stability
through change so we stay stable not by
resisting change but by changing